[Music]
brent is going to start off this hour in
akron ohio hi brent how are you
hi dave thanks for taking my call sure
um
what i am wondering i've never heard
anybody ask something like this before
is my wife and i have saved up
a good chunk of money to build a house
but until we get the rest of the savings
taken care of for building the house
we're wondering would it be a bad idea
to purchase a
uh
rental property or just an investment
property
and hold on to it for the next say
three four maybe five years until we get
the rest of our savings for building the
house
and then where are you living properly
where are you living
uh we are in a rental
um work
why would you buy an investment property
why would you buy something to live in
because
we are at a
we pay about half the going rate of
the
rate around our area we actually rent
from family
um
and we've been here about 25 years
we like where we're at
uh
and we have property to build on
already we already own the property
so we're just waiting to
get the rest of the money to build all
right so how much money have you got
right now
we got about 320 000 saved what's your
need
probably
originally it was probably going to be
about 400 and then covet hit now it's
probably going to be
five
maybe 550. what do you make household
income
um we bring in around before taxes
around 120.
okay so how long is it going to take you
to get this other 180
i'm figuring probably at least three
years yeah three or four is what i
thought
what's the purpose of buying the rental
property right now
just because right now we've got that
money parked in a money market account
but the
we're only getting like half a percent
right now yeah and what we were thinking
is if we did that for a couple of years
and resell it
we would get more of a return on that
money
than what we will get over that course
of time in the money market account
there's just a lot of risk in in there's
you're looking at all of the upside and
none of the downside with this rental
property situation
yeah the problem with real estate is
that it's sometimes hard to get out of
it's still it's an illiquid investment
okay you can't just decide i'm gonna
sell it now for the last three or four
years you can just decide you're gonna
sell a house and it's gone in 30 days
but that's not been a normal
way of doing real estate
except that's an unusual three year
period okay and if we go back if we go
into a slower real estate market which i
think we're going to
um
then you know you might have trouble
getting out of that thing when you want
to
uh-huh
you know and you don't want it and
there's a word there's a word for real
estate that sells really fast cheap
you give it away because you need the
money right and then all your theory of
making money goes out the window i
probably i love real estate but i
probably wouldn't do that i think you're
adding a lot of hassle to your life um i
would move some of the money into
probably an index fund just as that is
liquid in other words you can cash out
anytime you want but you're going to
make more than a half a percent over
three years
index fund follows the the stock market
and
you know uh i think over the next three
or four years you're gonna make some
money in that i better and a half a
percent for sure
i've got a bunch of money in that
myself and so um obviously i do believe
that that's what's happening so
um but i you know if you don't want to
move it all in there and maybe half of
it and you at least you'll make
something on it but i just i i'm not
gonna
the re i don't i'm not worried about the
investment property going down in value
i'm worried about the market slowing
down and you can't get out of it as
quickly as you need to
when you're finally ready to build this
dream house after 25 years of renting
you've got a specific timeline you're
looking for to do this in the next three
years it just feels like there's too
much on the line
yeah just to make a little money on it
and so if you make 10 on 300 000 is 30
000 bucks 30 000 bucks does not solve
this problem
it just keeps you from being aggravated
making no money in a money market that's
all it does
so uh i'm gonna move some of it or all
of it into an index fund but i don't
think i would do real estate in this
case because i don't know how quickly
the house is going to sell it's a great
long-term investment but in the short
term it could be volatile like that
we'll say we've said it over and over
and over for past three or four weeks
but um
it bears saying a lot more as a matter
of fact i think we're going to do an
event on this coming up we'll let y'all
know when and everything but real
estate's such a hot topic right now
there's so many things going on with it
but i am positive
okay
that real estate is not going to go down
in value in the next five years
some of you are going oh it's
artificially high it's going to go down
no it's not there's so much talk of the
crash right now there is not it's it's
simply not going to go down and let me
help you with this okay i've been doing
real estate for 30 years
it's a real simple equation
100
and i just taped the thing a few minutes
ago for the instagram goobies out there
with my with brooke who runs instagram
stuff but 100 of real estate prices is
based on supply demand
period
when there is more buyers than sellers
prices go up
when there is more sellers than buyers
prices go down now there's things that
affect how many buyers there are and how
many sellers there are but that's the
equation
you know inflation recession
stagflation idiots in the white house
high interest rates
affect the number of buyers
but unless the number of buyers goes
substantially below
the number of sellers
in the marketplace
you're not going to see prices go down
and we know that this is not going to
happen because it this year we have 128
million households in 2007 we had 116
million households 12 million more
households today that need houses in
2007 there were 2.1
million new housing
starts this year 1.4 million
the inventory available for sale of
houses right now is 50 percent of what
it was in 2007.
supply
is
drastically short
versus demand
prices are not going down there is not
going to be a real estate crash there's
nothing in this equation that says
there's going to be a real estate crash
nothing
and you can take it to the bank i've
told you some other stuff that came true
like i told you inflation was coming i
tell you stuff guys i've been doing this
a long time
i'm gonna wait on the house prices to go
down you're they're not going down
what goes up must go down you're wrong